let's talk about some goddamn video
games Gears of War for rod fergusson got
try to let onstage showed it off it's on
xbox play anywhere it's crossed by
cross-play cross everything Laura Bailey
came out and then we saw some hot
gameplay once again not during the
daytime this was maybe during the
daytime but the storm was so bad that it
felt like it was the nighttime Dave do
it do you think years of war force
campaign has daytime I hope so cuz damn
that game series bleak yes but I'm edge
before or roots saying that they need to
do something special for me to want to
get hype about Gears of War I again I'm
not sure they've done that why the set
pieces looked amazing the graphics
looked great but it still just looks by
the books gears of war yeah I suppose if
your gears of war fan that's exactly
what you want but you're a Gears of War
fan it's exactly how I write a bit more
new I want some I want a shot of
adrenaline into its spine I want to be
excited for gears again and while we've
seen some new set pieces upgraded
weapons it looks a lot nicer we've got
teased with an old Marcus I think that
was the only bit that makes you want to
pick it up again rival marks has been up
to I mean it looks great but again gray
isn't it's just more gears of war yeah i
mean that's bit they show it actually
this part here where they showed the the
turret firing at you and then when you
went up and pressed x on that thing's
dumb the editor to stop firing for no
reason I mean it's little okay yeah
didn't need to like breathing life into
this oh I mean uh I think I think this
game isn't isn't gory enough isn't
disgusting enough right like you called
it yeah do like I've like you've been
playing doom recently right yeah and it
is filthy yeah it's horrendous feeling
amazing dripping I feel like any a
shower yeah absolutely and this is like
a like a Diet Coke version of that right
you know it's not quite gruesome enough
i would say yeah it's a bit more
microsoft in epic games i think is well
you could say about gears of wars the
older they do have the Ripper from
unreal tournament in this game now which
is pretty cool yeah I mean I felt like a
lot of Twitter was having the same
reaction where it's like this is quite
safe right Mike yeah because I mean
going back to the first years of war the
thing that struck me after what like
nine years that how much it's just kill
these enemies advance the next thing I
kill these enemies of minutes the next
area I think the more we more shooters
we see the more we kind of appreciate
when they can contextualize the combat
and I'm like engaging or meaningful way
yeah the thing that struck me with this
was that like lightning storm part but
it wasn't even that you were just
dodging these things across this like
one parking lot yeah it seemed like the
person who's playing had played this
before a new where you have to go as
well though but I did needed something
like Dave said to actually convince me
they're still creative and they're not
out of energy with yes series even
though this is their first full original
game from the coalition and they're
obviously created specifically to make
these games so they know what they're
doing but is there still inspiration
there yeah I don't know I didn't it
doesn't look like it right now weird but
have to wait and see a lot of dialogue
in this which you know in a post
uncharted 4 world it's great to have all
that sort of stuff but then also it's a
post on charter for world don't you have
your by the number shooter anymore so
yeah we'll have to wait and see I guess
they were also releasing an xbox elite
controller for this so good job you want
to spend a lot of hot money on that
stuff